CREDITS.
ONLY THEY DIDN’T GET IT.
WE’RE JOINED NOW BY DONALD
TRUMP JR.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
LESSEN OF IMPEACHMENT IS
LESS LESSON OF IMPEACHMENT
IS OTHER THAN WE OWE UKRAINE
EVERYTHING WE HAVE.
WHAT’S YOUR TAKE AWAY FROM
THIS.
>> THE OBVIOUS LESSON IS
THAT THE DO-NOTHING
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO JUST
DO THAT, IMPEACHMENT DIDN’T
EVEN MEET NANCY PELOSI’ OWN
CRITERIA WHEN SHE SET THIS
OUT A FEW MONTH’S AGO.
THE REAL PROBLEM IS THE
DEMOCRATS AND NANCY ARE SO
BLINDED BY HATE, HATRED OF
DONALD TRUMP, THAT THEY
CAN’T EVEN FUNCTION.
THEY LITERALLY CANNOT DO
ANYTHING.
AS THEY ARE PUSHING THE
RUSSIA HOAX, DONALD TRUMP IS
SIGNING THE USMCA AND
GETTING THAT DONE.
FIXING NAFTA.
OKAY.
AS THEY ARE SIGNING THE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT,
TUCKER, HE IS SIGNING AN
HISTORIC TRADE DEAL WITH
CHINA.
HE STILL GOES ON, BUT THEIR
HATRED IS MAKING THEM MAKE
VERY BAD DECISIONS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE IT.
THEY SAW IT UP FRONT AND
CENTER LAST NIGHT AT THE
STATE OF THE UNION WHERE HE
HIGHLIGHTED SOME INCREDIBLE
AMERICAN STORIES.
WHETHER IT BE SOLDIERS,
WHETHER IT BE JUST GREAT
AMERICANA AND YOU SEE THEM
SITTING THERE NOT CLAPPING,
MISERABLE.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU
THE OBVIOUS POLITICAL
QUESTION.
THIS WAS A POLITICAL PROCESS
WITH POLITICAL GOALS.
THEY ARE NOT STUPID.
IT WAS CLEAR FROM DAY ONE
THAT THIS WAS LIKELY TO BE
COUNTERRODUCTIVE.
THEY WANTED TO HURT THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY HELPED HIM.
WHY DID THEY DO THIS?
>> BECAUSE NANCY PELOSI HAS
BEEN HUSHED BY PUSHED INTO THE C
FAR LEFT OF HER PARTY.
SHE IS NOT THE BRILLIANT
TACTICIAN EVERYBODY SAYS SHE
IS.
SHE HAS BEEN BULLIED BY A
PROGRESSIVE LEFT THAT HAS
ABSOLUTELY LOST THEIR MINDS.
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
NOT LOST THEIR WAY, TUCKER.
THEY GET IT.
THEY HAVE SEEN THROUGH THE
NONSENSE.
THEY SEE THAT THE
IMPEACHMENT HOAX, WHICH THEY
HAVE BEEN PUSHING, FOR THREE
AND A HALF YEARS NOW, IS
JUST THAT.
IT’S A HOAX.
OKAY.
THEY COULDN’T DO IT WITH
RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THIS IS JUST VERSION 3.0 AT
THIS POINT.
THEY HAVE LOST THAT BATTLE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT TO
SEE THEM GETTING IN THERE,
FIXING, MAYBE,
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF THINGS
THAT WE COULD DO.
INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD BE A
GREAT ONE FOR MY FATHER
BECAUSE HE IS ACTUALLY A
BUILDER, NOT A POLITICIAN.
HE WOULD DO INCREDIBLE
THINGS FOR AMERICA WITH
THAT.
BUT THEY COULD TACKLE DRUG
PRICING.
THEY COULD TACKLE ANY NUMBER
OF THINGS.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> YOUR VIEWERS CANNOT NAME
ONE THING THEY HAVE TACKLED
OTHER THAN RESIST DONALD
TRUMP AND HIS RECORD OF
SUCCESS.
>> Tucker: NOT EVEN SORT OF
INTERESTING MISSION FOR A
POLITICAL PARTY.
I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE VOTE
TODAY.
SO, LET’S SAY YOU DEVOTED
YOUR LIFE AS, YOU KNOW, AS A
BUSINESSMAN, BUYING
COMPANIES AND THEN FIRING A
LOT OF PEOPLE AND OFFSHORING
A LOT OF THE COMPANY AND YOU
GOT RICH DOING THAT
WHATEVER, A LOT OF PEOPLE DO
THAT PRIVATE EQUITY.
WOULD YOU BE IN A POSITION
TO DELIVER OVERWROUGHT MORAL
LECTURES TO OTHERS?
>> THE GENTLEMAN WHO DID
THAT IT’S IRONIC WHEN YOU
LOOK AT HIS POLITICAL
CAREER.
HE HAS FLIP FLOPPED FOR
POLITICAL EXPEDIENCY ON
EVERY MAJOR CONSERVATIVE
ISSUE THAT HE SAYS HE
BELIEVES IN NOW THAT HE IS
IN UTAH AGAIN.
GO LOOK AT THE RECORD GUYS
IT.
SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
TRACK RECORD ON LIFE.
THE REALITY IS.
THIS HE HAS COME TO DONALD
TRUMP OR HIS ENDORSEMENT FOR
MONEY WHEN HE WAS RUNNING.
HE BLEW HIS CHANCE BIGLY.
HE IS SO BITTER ABOUT IT HE
CANNOT LET IT GO, TUCKER.
HE CANNOT DO THE RIGHT
THING.
HE CANNOT DO WHAT THE PEOPLE
OF HIS STATE WANT.
HE IS PURELY, LIKE NANCY
PELOSI, JUST BLINDED BY
HATRED BECAUSE WHEN HE HAD
HIS SHOT, HE COULDN’T DO IT.
HE IS MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
ATTEMPTING TO BE LOVED BY
THOSE WHO HATE HIS GUTS, BY
THE MEDIA, BY THE LEFT, WHO
DESTROYED HIS POLITICAL
CAREER, WHO DESTROYED HIS
PRESIDENTIAL RUN THAN HE IS
ABOUT DOING WHAT HIS
CONSTITUENCY ACTUALLY WANTS.
AND IT’S BECOME NOW SO
TRANSPARENT THAT YOU CAN’T
EVEN HIDE FROM IT.
HE IS NOT BRAVE.
HE IS A COWARD.
>> Tucker: I JUST THINK IT’S
FUNNY THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE SO
ANGRY FEEL THE NEED.
RATHER THAN JUST BE ANGRY.
I DON’T LIKE YOU.
FEEL IT NECESSARY TO GIVE
YOU LECTURE.
>> WONDERFUL GUY.
LOOK AT THE RECORD.
IT SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.